i feel like atlanta is the one city in
our industry and hip-hop
in our culture that is literally
you need atlanta you need it
like you can't like like atlanta is what
is is is the taste maker of all cities
that's the one it don't matter who you
are you could be regional on the west
coast yeah you'll never be anything else
but a la or west coast artist and unless
you go tapping with atlanta you got to
tap in man and and we knew that you
think about yg right yg
harcourt la west coast i remember and
then the
cte [ __ ] happened and it might hit a
rich homie quasi
and that should put him on a whole
nother level exactly and and and it
worked same way in atlanta you know what
i'm saying if you even came up in
atlanta for so long you still you looked
at as atlanta artists now atlanta don't
need it i really don't think atlanta
needs la
because i think atlanta don't need la
but if you want to if you want to make
that bridge that gavin no no no
listeners
you know it's the west coast it's the
west you guys that's a big ass market
but the way i look at it is atlanta
music isn't regional music it's just
everywhere yeah
if you go to the club in
l.a 80 to 70 percent of the music you're
gonna hear is gonna either be from
atlanta yeah or from memphis yeah or
it's the south carolina stop going crazy
period you know what i'm saying now if
you go to the club in atlanta you're not
gonna know where you're not gonna hear
the west coast shot right here you might
hear something right ladies and
gentlemen you're going to hear the other
one yeah you might yeah no but outside
of that if you like atlanta you go to
new york yeah you're going to hear 70 to
80
south music you're gonna hear some new
york [ __ ] for sure because you're in new
york
i think that's the difference you got a
point atlanta's sound is
the united states yeah but it's so
different though it's like
the sound change so fast down that
[ __ ] though it does it it does
but it also it does but it like that's
what makes
atlanta so important
um
that's what makes atlanta so important
because it dictates
the sound everywhere exactly you know
what i'm saying i i i agree with you 100
yeah my whole life and i just seen a lot
of this [ __ ] i was like man i don't
understand artists who don't go tapping
in atlanta yeah i'll be seeing like
you got to man that's an artist all
artists can't tap in and london if we
ain't
there's an artist out here they named
caleb for real for real
yeah he did a great job of
going to the south first
tapping it with like
you know the homie dj win in florida and
going to atlanta and setting up was like
yo that's low-key like you got to do it
that way especially coming from this
side
you know what i'm saying but no that's
the homie though shout out to atlanta